we're going to begin with what is
happening in kenosha wisconsin
it is so disturbing and so upsetting and
it keeps happening this follows sunday's
shooting
of a black man by police shot seven
times
in the back a second day of peaceful
protest which is what the black lives
matter is really about
a peaceful protest gave way to clashes
overnight
police used tear gas and multiple
vehicles were burned
now it's not clear if those setting
fires were involved in the initial
demonstration
all this coming after 29 year old jacob
blake was shot multiple times in the
back by police
as he tried to get into his car he
remains hospitalized in stable condition
mololengi is in kenosha and a quick
warning we are about to show you
some disturbing video mola what are you
seeing this morning
well good morning anthony firefighters
just left this scene what
was a furniture store that was set on
fire overnight as you can see some
flames
rekindling there in the back the entire
site as you can see
still smoldering and firefighters are
still running around town dealing with
several sites
just like this one the governor deployed
125 members of the national guard here
yesterday
to help as those peaceful protests
during the day
turned destructive after the 8 pm curfew
protesters in kenosha defied a city-wide
curfew monday night and came
face-to-face with police
dressed in riot gear demonstrators are
calling for officers involved in jacob
blake's shooting
well setting this truck on fire right
here behind me is how some protesters
have responded
to the authority's use of stun grenades
of tear gas
sonic blasts all in an effort to try to
disperse protesters
who have stayed out past curfew shots
the clashes come in response to this
video police responding to a domestic
disturbance call sunday evening
complaint says jacob blake isn't
supposed to be there and he took the
complaints he's in refuse
is refusing to get them back the initial
encounter with police was not
captured on the video the footage shows
blake walking towards his car
at least one officer with his gun drawn
follows him that officer then grabs his
shirt
before appearing to fire his weapon into
blake's back at least seven times
it seems to be when it's a black
american
they shoot first and then try to justify
it later
blake's lawyer ben crump says blake had
been trying to de-escalate the domestic
disturbance
according to crump blake's three young
sons were in the car at the time of the
shooting
and police tased blake before opening
fire rayshawn white who asked that we
not show his face on camera
says he recorded the incident on his
cell phone did it just keep getting
worse and worse
i heard them say drop the knife i didn't
see a knife in his hands
in a statement the kenosha police union
urged people to know the facts before
passing judgment
saying as always the video currently
circulating does not capture
all the intricacies of a highly dynamic
incident what's your response to that
what you see with your eyes is the
tragedy that should have never
happened by people who were supposed to
be trained professionals
to de-escalate the situation and the
video
speaks for itself
the officers involved in the incident
have been placed on leave their
identities have not yet been announced
tony yeah in the context of everything
here
mola black men and boys die at twice the
rate more than twice the rate in fact of
their white peers that's why there's
such
outrage this morning and overnight
mullah thank you very much